[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's millions
of americans returned to air travel last
year after covet nearly brought it to a
halt tsa workers screened more than 585
million passengers at airport
checkpoints into in 2021 thousands of
them were carrying something you
shouldn't have at an airport a loaded
gun
only on cbs mornings the tsa
administrator spoke to errol barnett
about this very disturbing trend he's at
washington's reagan national airport
right now with more on the story errol
i'm feeling a little nervous between
covid the 5g threat and now this latest
report
feeling some kind of way about getting
on a plane but good morning to you again
i know it i know it gail good morning
well we've got to inform our viewers
here the tsa tells cbs news nearly 6 000
firearms were intercepted at security
checkpoints nationwide last year and
that completely crushed the previous
record in 2019 by more than fifteen
hundred and yes indeed an alarming
number of these guns were loaded
about 86 percent of those firearms are
loaded and that presents a significant
both safety and security concern tsa
administrator david pokowski is worried
about the record increase in guns
discovered at checkpoints last year even
as travel remained below pre-pandemic
levels what's causing it i don't know
exactly but generally i think our
weapons carriage detections reflect just
more people carrying weapons in the
country
atlanta's hartsville jackson was at the
top of the tsa's list 507 firearms were
detected in 2021 up from
23 in 2019.
and this was the scene after a gun was
found by a tsa officer last november
when the suspect reached in and
accidentally discharged his weapon
causing chaos at the world's busiest
airport that illustrates why loaded
weapons are so dangerous because it's
very easy to discharge those weapons
when that passenger lunged for the bag
he discharged
that firearm into the checkpoint dallas
houston phoenix and nashville round out
the top five we know that there are a
lot of new gun owners the national
shooting sports foundation a firearm
industry trade association which tracks
background checks says gun sales are up
nationwide
in 2020 more than 8.4 million people
bought a gun for the first time
and that year a record 21 million
background checks were conducted
compared to more than 13 million the
year before passengers can't travel with
the gun on an aircraft but only safely
and securely as checked luggage for
those who do choose to travel with their
firearm to understand that it is
possible and there's a way to do that
make sure that you secure that firearm
either in the proper travel bags that
you can have that you can go through tsa
with or you make sure it's locked up
before you even leave the home peckovsky
warns carrying a gun through a
checkpoint will cost you know that if
you do have a weapon and it's detected
in the checkpoint it's first going to
take you a lot more time secondly there
might be local law enforcement action
and third we will follow up with a civil
penalty action so it's a very costly
mistake to me
now that fine is nearly fourteen
thousand dollars in addition to whatever
charges local police will bring and
you'll lose your tsa pre-check all of
that pretty costly for something that's
absolutely preventable by the way here
at reagan national 30 guns were
intercepted by tsa at the checkpoint
here last year back to you all the table
wow that's sort of jaw-dropping arrow
barnett reporting from the airport but
but to reassure you i think these people
are not trying to get a gun on a plane
they're forgetting that they carry a gun
all the time or and it's normal for them
and then they get caught with it you
know what that says to me it says that
people are more concerned about their
safety than ever before well yeah i mean
the sales are crazy yeah sales are going
up and people have these guns especially
in these open carry states
it's unfortunate scary stuff and the big
issue is if you fly from an open carry
state to a non-open carry state you land
in new york city for example then you're
in big trouble yeah because the laws are
different yeah very soon you both can
see how people can forget that you have
a gun yeah you do
for some people it's like a tool on
their hip like so they don't think
they've got a phone in their pocket yeah
for sure it's not the wild wild west
though no yeah i'm glad that girl did
that report errol thank you so much